lo que quiero hacer es empezar con una
expresión como 4x + 18 y escribirla como
una multiplicación de dos expresiones
básicamente lo que quiero hacer es
factorizar esta expresión y la clave
aquí es ver si 4x y 18 tienen factores
comunes y una vez que los encontremos
factorizar los utilizar algo así como el
reverso de la propiedad distributiva y
de esa forma escribir a esta expresión
como ese factor común por la suma de
otros dos términos entonces cuál es el
número más grande que divide tanto a 4x
como a 18 bueno de hecho en lugar de
decir el número más grande debería yo
decir la expresión más grande pero en
este caso esa expresión va a ser un solo
número y veamos cuál es ese número
sabemos que el 2 divide al 4 y por lo
tanto 2 también divide a 4 por equis y 2
también divide a 18 entonces en esta
expresión podemos factorizar un 2
este 4 lo podemos escribir como 2 por y
ahora 4x entre 2 es 2x y este 18 lo
podemos escribir como 2 por 9 ok
entonces ya que escribimos esta
expresión de esta forma podemos utilizar
algo así como la propiedad distributiva
inversa porque esto se parece muchísimo
a lo que nos queda cuando aplicamos la
propiedad distributiva no entonces lo
que vamos a hacer es agrupar este 2
por aquí
y adentro de este paréntesis tiene que
ir 2x este 2x más
9 este 9 entonces si aplicamos la famosa
propiedad distributiva lo que nos queda
es 2 x 2 x que es este término más 2 x 9
que es este término y a su vez esta
expresión es igual a esta expresión
entonces ya terminamos ya escribimos a
4x + 18 como el producto de dos
expresiones de 2 y de 2 x 29 entonces
hagamos otro ejemplo
por ejemplo 12 más 32 x aunque sabes que
mejor en lugar de usar la variable x
vamos a usar la variable ya para tener
un poco de diversidad es exactamente lo
mismo estas dos son variables
simplemente las estamos llamando de otra
forma y queremos factorizar esta
expresión escribirla como un producto de
dos expresiones así es que tenemos que
buscar cuál es la expresión más grande
que divide tanto a 12 como a 32 ya y
bueno para empezar podemos ver
directamente que el 2 divide tanto a
12,32 ye porque el 2 divide a 32 pero
eso no es lo único
a ver 12 lo podemos escribir como 4 por
3 y 32 es igual a 4 por 8 así es que el
4 divide a ambos suman 2 y además es el
máximo común divisor entre 12 y 32
porque el 3 no divide a 32 y que tampoco
divide a 12 entonces lo que vamos a
hacer es factorizar ese 4 de esta
expresión ok este 12 lo podemos escribir
como 4 por y aquí lo que tiene que ir es
un 3 y por acá este 32 ya lo podemos
escribir como 4 por este 32 de entre 4
es igual a 8 por 8 y muy bien y ahora lo
que vamos a hacer es aplicar la
propiedad distributiva inversa otra vez
o sea que vamos a agrupar este 4
este 4 también lo que nos queda es 4 por
este 3 más 8 y 8 de hockey si
desarrollamos esta multiplicación nos
queda por la propiedad distributiva 4
por 3 que es 12 más 4 por 8 y que es 32
y listo ya factor izamos esta otra
expresión